chaque jour davantage nous écrivons
l'histoire le chemin de l'Europe sociale
cette Europe juste qui garantit les
droits à tous ces citoyens sans aucune
distinction cette Europe verte qui
engage tous ces citoyens dans la
transition climatique cette Europe
réactive qui protège tous ces citoyens
face à la pandémie de la covid ou
l'agression illégale de l'Ukraine ça a
l'air minimum transparence des
rémunérations protection des
travailleurs des plateformes deviennent
des réalités tangibles grâce à notre
action et notre détermination et à
l'inverse chaque jour davantage sur les
plateaux télé les populistes d'extrême
droite vous racontent des histoires ils
se font les chantres du pouvoir d'achat
mais ici où nous pouvons changer les
choses ou nous faisons les lois il
rejette chaque texte chaque avancée que
nous obtenons pour la protection et la
convergence sociale demain encore il
n'hésiteront pas à voter contre cette
résolution
l'hypocrisie l'imposture l'escroquerie
il est temps de les dénoncer voter c'est
écrit à l'histoire alors continuons
ensemble à tracer l'histoire de l'Europe
sociale
[Applaudissements]